he's now a baseball executive and
baseball hall-of-famer and on the day
after Mariano Rivera and Mike Mussina
both going to the Hall of Fame but
Rivera as the first unanimous selected
player we ought to have one of one of
Cooperstown finest on the program Joe
Torre how are you Joe
I'm good rich thank you for that
introduction I I have to night now you
make me work harder you know what I know
how to butter up the guest but uh but
it's it's it's well deserved your
thoughts on Moby in the first unanimous
selected member of the Baseball Hall of
Fame is what Joe
well not surprised again there are
certain philosophies I guess on on
behalf of the writers that some you know
don't feel that anybody should go in on
the first ballot and you know and then I
read something about you know close
their only pitches one inning and but I
guess you have to realize how important
those three outs where I could say that
but you know he he was for as long as he
pitched rich and I know totals will show
you that he really never changed the
kind of pitcher he was you know there
are so many pitchers and especially you
know relief pitchers who have had to
change their style because their stuff
was diminished but Mariano really never
once he discovered that cutter he just
learned to do different things with it
and and he just became a little more of
a complete picture but it didn't
surprise me really that he was unanimous
because it'd be tough for me to be the
one to say well let me give me a reason
not to put him on you know the ballot
right I mean you mentioned the three
outs of being so important when he first
started as a reliever it was really six
outs you were getting from him on
average prior to wetland and seventh and
eighth innings of that 96 season when
you first got to New York as the manager
and he was a kid that had ten starts in
the ninety five season what did you see
the first time he lays on you laid eyes
on Mariano Rivera
Joe well you know rich the first time I
saw him was on TV the the year before
when he pitched against Seattle in in
that final game I guess it was Game five
you know and where the Yankees lost Game
five after being up two games to none
and watched him come out of that bullpen
in that extra inning game and he you
know he looked pretty impressive you
know of course then you hear the stories
about you know surgery and you know he
had some issues so he was in spring
training with us in 96 and you know I'm
a I'm a lifelong national league guy and
everything was new for me and you know
he had no options left so we knew he was
on the team there was some scuttlebutt
and you know when Jeter was scuffling
all spring you know there was some talk
about sending him to the minor leagues
and making a deal for a shortstop and
Mariano was mentioned in that you know
supposed a deal so you know he was sort
of excess baggage at that time even
though you knew he had he had some kind
of value but who would have dreamed that
he would have you know be sitting there
in the Hall of Fame at this point Joe
you just gave me a little bit of a heart
attack even though I know the way
everything worked out you're saying that
there was a possibility of not starting
Jeter in 96 in sending Rivera packing
for his replacement is that what you're
telling me Joe that was possible yeah
that that was that's public knowledge
yeah yeah you know toward the end of
spring training there was a comment from
one of George's advisors that Mariano I
mean that Derek may not be ready because
you know he didn't have a particularly
good spring and I'll tell you when the
season started he did there was like
somebody just flipped a switch but it
got late in the spring and I was one of
the dissenters on that I said no we you
know we've had him here all spring and
then and this kid shows up every day and
really hasn't done anything wrong it
doesn't hit but spring training doesn't
really bother me and you know there was
some conversation and part of the
conversation was you know we have you
know all these relief coaches we had
wetland we had Bob Wickman
you know and then of course Mariano
Rivera who we didn't know was going to
be a closer you know we discovered that
in 96 when as you mentioned earlier you
know he was the setup man for wetland
and so he was sort of a player that a
pitcher that we didn't know what his
role was because you know his options
were used up so he was obviously going
to stay with the team and there was some
talk about you know training him for a
for mean I think it was from Seattle you
know and and again I don't know how
close that got to being made I know was
talked about Joe Torre baseball
hall-of-famer here on the Rich Eisen
show what's your favorite Mariano story
when I guess you were in the crucible of
a game or you know that there was a big
series finale coming up that you knew
you how to use him or you you'd used him
so much and he's basically told you he
was ready give me give me something that
maybe he leaps out to your mind here Joe
the day after him getting into the Hall
unanimously well the one you know Boston
it was such you know eventually they
caught up with him unity you face the
team 19 times I'm not a big fan of you
know scheduling where you face so many
so many of one team so many times and I
remember we had this was a game during
the season and you know he had command
and you know and and there Pedroia
fouled off it felt like a hundred and
fifty pitches you know he just kept
falling them off on off on off it was a
one-run game and he winds up walking
Pedroia and now Big Papi is the next
hitter and now there is either first and
second or first second and third I think
it was first and second the tying runs
at second base bottom in a ninth-inning
Fenway Park and I just go out to the
mound and I have no idea what I'm going
to say but I know he just really
partially exhausted himself just trying
to get the joy out
so I get out to the mound and everybody
comes in like you're gonna listen to
some revelation from their manager and I
you know and and all the other players
are in there and I said to Moe I said
well I guess you'd better get this guy
out I left and you know I just wanted to
give him a chance to catch his breath
you know and I look at Jeter and there's
only he always given me some kind of an
expression and you know he had a little
smirk on his face and went back to his
position but that was that was the one
that comes to mind for me because it's a
helpless feeling when you know he's
going to be the one you're leaving in
the game and you know he doesn't need
any motivation but I just thought I'd
give him a chance to catch his breath
and now his name Joe is synonymous with
you know closing something out whether
it's not just baseball or sports or just
a life you know somebody goes into a
meeting you know and you will get you
gotta bring in Rivera right you bring in
Rivera to close it up I mean his name is
synonymous with that now and I'm
wondering when when did you start
realizing that about him with well you
know in that first year obviously when
you know he pitched those seventh and
eighth innings and it felt like he
pitched every single day and and you
know Zimmer who was my bench coach we
looked at each other when when he'd come
into the game and you know you were sort
of sorry you had to take him out even
though wetland did a great job for us
and so when we started 97 you know and
wetland became a free agent and in April
we were facing Oakland and the Yankee
Stadium and he faced the same batter
twice in the same game and you know for
a closer that's not a very good thing to
do if I said Dome after the game I said
pal this is yours it may take you a
while to get used to it but it took a
little adjusting for him but I think he
still wound up saving 40 games I think
and you know and that's 97 but he he was
special right from the get-go and it's
just a remarkable story when you know
Mel stottlemyre and and he were in the
bullpen and you know he was you know
just warming up and he discovered that
cutter you and the cutter came and sewn
they weren't working anything no kidding
and yeah that's how I hate just they
what do you think of that let's do it
again let's see any and he just had that
natural cutter and that became his
lifeline its shorted I mean my gosh and
and you know I'm appreciative do couple
minutes left with Joe Torre baseball
hall-of-famer that you mentioned Mel
stottlemyre named certainly with Mike
Mussina going in as well together with
Mariano Rivera you're coming back from
Mel stottlemyre funeral I wonder what
Mel would have thought to hear about the
news of Moe being anonymous and he goes
in with Mike Mussina Joe well he would
have been very very proud of both of
them Mel was a special not only a
special pitching coach just a special
person you know he treated guys whether
you won 20 games or just pitched 20
innings like you were the most important
picture on our staff and he's you know
he's going to be missed it was a very
emotional day yesterday but he certainly
would be very proud of these two guys
going in yeah and there's boats name was
mowin the ninth right that's what David
does right now and the ninth he named as
we've got him a boat when he retired and
yeah Mariano is funny because I tried to
reach him yesterday and I'm not
surprised and went to voicemail and I
sent a text message and then all of a
sudden I get a phone call and he had me
on speaker with his whole family which
was pretty cool it was a great
experience for me and he was he was very
very excited yeah we could I said to him
I said the one thing you know you know
you're the first unanimous choice there
may be others I said but nobody will
ever be the first so it was quite an
accomplishment also the last guy to wear
number 42 Joe - that's right you know
ask guy to win Jackie's nothing where
Jackie's number and he's certain Jackie
would have been proud also so special it
really really isn't it's special for me
personally and the show to have you
calling the day after like this Joe I
really appreciate it
anytime rich haven't seen you since we
were walking down the street in LA that
one day that's right it's been a while
so let's make sure it doesn't go this
long again I really appreciate that
chat to time in the memories enjoy the
Super Bowl I will do that you got it you
got a thought on it Joe I know you're
big football guy I just you know Los
Angeles is there's such an up-and-coming
team and they got their taste last year
but the one thing I've always admired
about well Bobby Cox Ville won and and
Bill Belichick is the fact that they
that his team's play every single play
of every single game and it's it's so
admirable for me as a sports person to
to really watch how they go about their
business yeah I do you have a
relationship with Bill or you've you met
him a few I do I I do yeah fact I did
his charity during the playoffs up there
in Boston he's he's been a friend you
know he's visited our spring training
and I know he's visited LaRussa's spring
training he's a big baseball fan but
he's remarkable and his career and how
it stays brand new for him all the time
Joe let's chat again soon thanks again
for the call travel well okay rich you
back here that's Joe Torre baseball
hall-of-famer
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience